we're going to turn now to a growing
crisis in America a potential water
shortage affecting tens of millions of
people talking about the Colorado River
which stretches all the way from the
Rocky Mountains to the Gulf of
California and it is dwindling that
River supplies water to Farms that feed
not just that area of the country but
the entire country and it is also a
crucial power source in the area and now
the federal government says it's getting
so bad they are on the verge of stepping
in Ben Tracy has the latest now on what
has become an escalating water war in
the West
The Binding Administration warned of
potentially drastic cuts to come in
front of Lake Mead the nation's largest
Reservoir it's now less than 30 percent
full after Decades of overuse and
devastating drought we can expect water
levels to continue to decline
threatening the operations of the system
and the water supply of 40 million
people
despite a very wet winter in the west
the crisis on the Colorado is so dire
the federal government is worried Lake
Mead and Lake Powell could hit what's
known as Deadpool when water no longer
flows under the massive Glen Canyon in
Hoover dams cutting off Colorado River
water to Western cities including Las
Vegas Phoenix and Los Angeles as well as
millions of Acres of Farmland we cannot
Kick the Can on finding Solutions under
one proposal the Interior Department
would impose even cuts of up to 25
percent on California Arizona and Nevada
a second option would largely spare
California because of its senior water
rights but hit Arizona hard
so what we're boating under you used to
be able to boat over you used to be able
to Bow over the top of this bridge last
year we visited Arizona's Lake Powell
the second largest Reservoir in the
country has dropped so low one sunken
rock formations can be seen for the
first time in decades and there are
fears the Glen Canyon Dam could stop
generating hydropower for millions of
people in the West
now the department of the Interior says
it's not picking aside yet on how to
make these water Cuts but if the states
don't come to an agreement on their own
it will make a decision imposing cuts on
them later this summer Tony all right
Ben thank you very much